welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
tuesday morning dan hooker tweeted his
desire to return to the lightweight
division and he has his next opponent in
mind responding to a fan suggesting
hooker faced tony ferguson the new
zealander didn't hold back
you want to play ball step up to the
plate at tony ferguson xt
he followed that up just six minutes
later with a tweet of his own
accompanied by a popular meme i'll smash
your face in at tony ferguson xt both
fighters household names in the ufc have
recently fallen on hard times with just
one win in their past nine fights
combined hooker last fought in the
featherweight division a loss to arnold
allen but prior to that he had been
fighting at 155 pounds since 2017. tony
ferguson on the other hand is coming off
of a front kick knockout loss to michael
chandler immediately following the main
event at ufc 277 welterweight bala
muhammad tweeted that he would like to
see a trilogy between amanda nunez and
juliana pena who lost followers on the
other hand reacted the opposite way
claiming that the fight was so one-sided
by nunes a third fight was not needed
the response prompted muhammad to post a
video furthering his stance and even
going as far as taking shots at amanda
nunez
i just wanted to talk about the fights
yesterday
i got a lot a lot of haters on my posts
saying they deserve a trilogy fight for
that main event
big shout out to juliana pena
the heart she showed the mentality she
showed she showed why she was a champion
and why that first fight wasn't a fluke
to all the haters saying oh it was a
fluke just showed it blah blah blah like
look how tough she showed herself she
had moments in this fight where she
almost caught her in the arm bar she
landed big punches on her you guys are
just all straight up haters that oh
what's your face dominated her she
dominated her bro get the heck out of
here she was so close to getting the arm
bar she landed big punches yeah she got
rocked a couple times that could have
changed the whole aspect of the fight um
who knows how she recovered off those uh
knockdowns early in the first round
and
there's girls that would have literally
laid there and got taken down or gave up
like amanda did the first fight
so for all you people saying oh wow she
didn't deserve it blah blah blah like
juliana won the first fight by finish
man i know you just didn't so that's why
i deserve a trilogy fight
you could say what the score was
50 44 50 43
but
that doesn't
talk about the whole fight there was
moments in that fight where juliana
could have won that fight
um
and just want to give out huge respect
for her amanda i feel like
getting too cocky she's getting a little
arrogant saying oh i could have went
five rounds if i could have finished her
in the first round if i wanted to uh but
i wanted to go five rounds so i could
show her who's better blah blah blah get
out of here with that you couldn't
finish her i think emmanuel amanda
started taking her down in the third
fourth and fifth round because
she didn't want to get caught again on
the feet she knows that uh juliana
punches hard her eye was very swollen
she was on crutches leaving so she was
definitely in a fight it wasn't a
dominating fight like a lot of people
are making it out to be
um
yeah so
for all the people that are hating on
juliana fudge fudgy ufc welterweight
colby covington reportedly took seventh
place in a major south florida poker
tournament a tweet from annie slater
shows covington at the tournament and
gives more details on his reported
payout ufc star colby covington makes
final table of record-setting poker
tournament at hard rock hawley in
florida beating 7696
other entrants he gets 48
298 of the 2.5 million dollar prize pool
for finishing 7th
espn's brett akamoto tweeted about a
reported new addition to the ufc 280 in
abu dhabi according to his sources
muhammad mohayev will take on malcolm
gordon in abu dhabi on october 22nd
muhammad mohave has his next date and
opponent mohaya vs malcolm gordon agreed
to for ufc 280 in abu dhabi per sources
gordon on a two-fight win streak
muhammad most recently fought at ufc
london on july 23rd where he won in a
three-round decision and made headlines
after by taking shots at paddy pimblet's
character
jake paul's most valuable promotions
business partner nakisa bidarian
responded to dana white's comments about
the cancelled bout between jake paul and
haseem rahman jr at the ufc 277 post
fight press conference white theorized
that the fight was cancelled due to low
ticket sales and advised paul to
surround himself with better business
partners bidarian a former ufc
accountant responded to white in an
instagram story we're supposed to be
here saturday for a big fight but we had
to cancel driven by fighter health and
safety and liability potential we will
be back we are working on it it had zero
to do with ticket sales we already sold
more tickets more gate than ryan garcia
just did at staples center we were going
to be top 10 in gates since 2005 for
boxing at madison square garden and jake
paul was taking a big challenge all of
his fights have been at about 188 to 191
pounds and all of his opponents outside
of nate robinson have been plus or minus
one to two pounds of him they can try to
change the narrative they can try to
destroy what this young man has done i'm
proud of him he's his own boss he's his
own promoter and i'm just an accountant
ufc heavyweight tom aspinall gave his
fans an update on his knee injury that
he suffered 15 seconds into his
headlining bout with curtis blades at
ufc london on july 23rd in the video
aspinal revealed that he sustained heavy
damage to the knee tearing both his mcl
and his meniscus as well as inflicting
damage on the acl aspinall posted the
video right before heading into surgery
in london
morning everybody
today is surgery day i'm in london right
now and uh
absolutely starving because okay before
surgery and um
yeah i have suffered a torn mcl
a
meniscus and
some acl damage so i'm going to get that
fixed today but just a quick message
just to say thank you for all the
support really appreciate it i've had so
much love since the accident
and i'll see everybody on the side peace
out tuesday night dana white's contender
series returned for its second week of
season six after the season premiere
featured lackluster bouts and only one
contract awarded white urged future
competitors to step it up and they did
just that only one of the five bouts
tuesday went to decision and white was
so impressed with the performances he
awarded contracts to all five of the
winners in the featured bout chris
duncan knocked out charlie campbell in
the first round after being close to
getting finished himself in his
post-fight press conference duncan
talked about being on his heels during
the fight but knowing what he needed to
do to secure the contract i made a bit
of a mess of it but it's not how you
start it's how you finish he was rushing
in i watched some footage on him a while
ago and when he starts to get his groove
he starts weaving and bobbing with his
hands i saw him doing that and i just
got my head off the center line and just
threw my cannon and threw it right to
his chops i bounced his head off the
canvas putting someone down like that is
never nice but that's what i'm going for
and i knew that's what was going to
secure me my contract
aside from duncan the contract winners
are vinicius salvador francis marshall
waldo cortez acosta and billy gough
after the event dana personally
congratulated each winner
what a night congrats
this is what i'm talking about
you know on the internet we're number
two worldwide wow so do you remember
what i told you i said this is your gift
thank you
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
you